[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
I'm Brian buckmeyer We are following a
new high profile celebrity case rapper
Ryan W mellies is charged with two
murders and jury selection is now
underway in Florida
the accusations against the melee whose
given name is Jamel demons made
headlines all over the country just four
months before the 2018 killings melee
released a song called Murder on My Mind
in October of that year mellie's best
friend Cortland Henry showed up at a
Miami Hospital claiming his friends were
caught in a drive-by shooting and were
bleeding out in his car Anthony Williams
and Christopher Thomas had multiple
gunshot wounds and were pronounced dead
Henry told officers they were shot at
while leaving a recording studio in
nearby Fort Lauderdale but when police
got there there was no evidence that a
shooting happened they found
surveillance video that showed the three
men in the car along with ynw Melly
investigators determined the victims
were shot by someone in the car not in a
drive-by police arrested Mellie and
Cortland Henry on two counts of
first-degree murder each they are being
tried separately and have both pled not
guilty because police believe Melly is
the one who actually fired the shots he
has been in jail since 2019. potential
jurors will have to decide whether he
should be he should get the death
penalty if convicted Henry was released
on bail and does not face the death
penalty
I'm joined by my co-host former trial
Attorney Terry Austin and our special
guest today former homicide prosecutor
Bernardo villalona Bernardo this trial
will be one of the first death penalty
cases after the Parkland school shooter
got life in prison under a new law the
vote for death has to be eight to four
how will it affect this trial
well the way it's going to affect the
trial is exactly what governor DeSantis
his aim was in order to get a lower
amount of jurors necessary to reach the
death penalty in which she just signed
off a couple of weeks ago as a result of
this we're going to find that more
people are going to be sentenced to
death now Florida has the lowest
threshold in order to have the death
penalty imposed because you have Alabama
Alabama only requires a vote of 10 uh to
two in order to get the death penalty
imposed and two other states it requires
if the juries are deadlocked that the
judge actually makes the decision so
this is going to have a huge impact not
only on this case but on other cases
where defendants are facing the death
penalty yeah this makes me think if they
come back seven or five are they going
to try to change the law again well
Terry the state made a motion to take
photographs of melee what is the purpose
of that and should it motion be granted
well the motion doesn't mention anything
about tattoos but the theory is the
state wanted to take pictures of
mellie's body because it has tattoos of
gang-related activity and so now that
the grand jury has brought an indictment
and it is connected with this gang
activity now they want to take these
pictures they want to see the photos and
they want to probably introduce that
into evidence yeah if not for the case
in Chief that at the very least he was
convicted at sentencing well we have an
update for you on a sex abuse case
involving actor Cuba Gooding Jr we told
you Monday his Civil Trial in New York
was supposed to start Tuesday now he'll
avoid trial according to court records
Gooding settled the case with a woman
who filed the lawsuit anonymously the
exact details of the settlements were
not released Jane Doe had accused
Gooding of raping her in a Manhattan
hotel room after they met in a bar last
year Gooding pled guilty to forcibly
kissing a worker at a New York nightclub
after he completed therapy he was able
to withdraw the guilty plea and the
charge was downgraded to a non-criminal
harassment violation
the mother of a six-year-old who shot at
a teacher inside a first grade classroom
in Virginia will plead guilty into new
federal charges Deja Taylor is accused
of unlawful use of marijuana in
possession of a handgun and making a
false statement about her drug use when
purchasing the firearm both are felony
charges prosecutors say they don't plan
to charge the boy because of his age
he's accused of taking his mother's gun
to school and intentionally shooting
Abby's Werner fortunately she survived
and is recovering Taylor pled not guilty
to State charges of child neglect and
Reckless storage of a firearm
you're on vandersloe the main suspect in
The Disappearance of Alabama teenager
Natalie Holloway is fighting his
extradition back to the United States
vandersloat is supposed to be extradited
from Peru to the United States Thursday
morning vandersold has was never charged
in connection with Holloway's
disappearance but is charged with
extorting money from her family
prosecutors say in 2010 vandersload
accepted 25 thousand dollars in cash
from the family in exchange for the
location of Holloway's body after the
money was transferred a sting operation
was done and vandersloe pointed to the
house he claimed Holloway was buried in
he later admitted to lying about the
location his attorney says vandersload
wasn't notified that there was an open
extradition process so he didn't have a
chance to challenge it it's up to a jury
to determine if a former NFL player is
guilty of murder or acted in
self-defense when he fired dozens of
shots at an SUV we're breaking down the
closing arguments next
welcome back our former NFL player
charged with murder could soon learn his
fate attorneys gave closing arguments in
Travis Rudolph's trial on Tuesday when
is to say Rudolph got into a physical
fight with his now ex-girlfriend
Dominique Jones in April of 2021. that's
when Jones reportedly texted her brother
to bring a group of men to Rudolph's
home to confront him four men showed up
and a brawl broke out as the group of
men was leaving prosecutors argue that
Rudolph shot at them 39 times killing
21-year-old Sebastian Jean-Jacques he
was in the passenger seat of a car when
he was shot 10 times another man was
injured but survived a stand your ground
hearing was held but the judge ruled
Rudolph couldn't use a defense because
the men were trying to get away when he
shot at them Rudolph testified in his
own defense on Monday and jury
instructions were read before closing
the arguments on Tuesday here's what the
attorneys had to say
ladies and gentlemen I submit to you
even under the unlikely circumstances
that they had firearms
and in fact pointed them
think about what those men would have
seen
this firearm
big one Sig Sauer
with the drum
heavy thing by the way you're allowed to
touch things
coming at them from somebody who's
running towards them or walking towards
them
somebody there trying to escape someone
whom they're literally trying to flee
they would have had every right to turn
guns on him at that moment
but ladies and gentlemen I submit to you
that did not happen they did not have
time
they didn't have time
they got in that car the car started
moving and they were screeching away or
trying to
Hell hath no fury
like a woman scorned
great argument by opposing counsel but
forgot to talk to you about the facts of
the case
about what the witnesses said
about detective mandolin her lack of
Investigation
I didn't know any better
I was watching an episode of The
Sopranos
it's just the names changed
somebody disrespected
a mobster's daughter
and they went to go lock them
so go kill him that's what this case
really is
not just a video that shows you what it
shows you of course it doesn't lie but
it doesn't show you the whole story
at the moment of truth you can't see
who's in that car and what they're doing
or not doing
you'll never know it's impossible
State can argue all they want they
weren't there
shameful that you didn't get to see the
real evidence in this case
it's a shame that nobody cared
thank God he had lawyers that cared
how much of this case rests on Rudolph's
testimony and did he do enough for an
acquittal or or the very least a hung
jury
thanks Travis well Rudolph is going to
have a hard time a difficult time in
trying to convince 12 jurors to believe
that he was justified in shooting up a
moving vehicle especially if you have
one of the decedents that was shot at
fire 10 times the numbers just don't
make sense and also the fact that these
people were actually leaving the
location as opposed to going towards him
which is crucial but I think if anything
is all going to depend on The
credibility the believability until we
came off to those 12 jurors but it's
going to be very difficult for him to
get an all right ago possibly the best
terms that he'll get is a hung jury yeah
maybe a few believe him uh Terry the
prosecution asked for a lesser included
charges does that help or hurt the
defendant well in this case I think it's
going to hurt the dependent defendant I
think he did a decent job when he did
his direct exam and when he did his
cross exam I think it was very clear to
that jury that it wasn't premeditated so
first degree no even second degree where
you have a depraved mind I think it was
clear he didn't come come out there with
a depraved mine he came out and
initially he was not even carrying a gun
but I think those lesser included
manslaughter showing culpable negligence
might be a bit easier they have the
assault and battery now also so I do
think it'll be a little more difficult
for him to get a complete acquittal so
those jurors are going to look at those
lesser charges and they're going to say
well maybe he didn't do first degree or
second degree but maybe it was
manslaughter so I think it's going to
hurt him at the end of the day who knows
maybe we'll have a hung jury yeah well
we of course will be keeping track and
an eye on this case has during The
Liberation will begin or continue
shortly